les vendanges c'est le tout début dans
le sud de la france à rivesaltes dans
les pyrénées orientales on récolte déjà
le raisin qui va être utilisé pour la
confection du muscat un vin doux gorgés
de soleil karine comazzi frédéric bibal
après une semaine de météo capricieuse
sur les pyrénées la tramontane s'élever
à point pour sécher les vignes à
rivesaltes dans les rangées de muscat on
cueille sans relâche alors je compte et
c'est là que c'est alors que puis-je
parce que la moto qui l'avaient voilà
soixante ans que monsieur petit chat
dort père veille aux petits grains de
son précieux muscat 60 vendanges à la
main et jean n'en a manqué aucune the
brain gym à notre combientième bornage
1948 le muscat doux c'est ce qui fait
vivre les viticulteurs du roussillon
pour cet exploitant le muscat représente
25% de la production mais 40% du chiffre
d'affaires
depuis six ans les vins doux de
rivesaltes s'efforce de conquérir de
nouveaux publics sur un marché des
apéritifs très concurrentiel c'est ça
c'est vraiment des jeunes des femmes
aussi qui adore se produit parce qu'elle
s'y retrouve je dirais le fruit le
soleil convoi pendant les vacances et
donc c'est un produit qui actuellement
est en relativement bon sur les 240
mille hectolitres de muscat produit
chaque année en france essentiellement
languedoc roussillon 170 mille
hectolitres proviennent du terroir de
rivesaltes
la particularité du muscat
roussillonnais c'est le mélange à parts
égales de deux sortes de raisin muscat
petits grains et muscat d'alexandrie qui
lie à minimum 14 degrés st
cette année là c'est vrai qu'on a eu la
particularité d'avoir un été et pas été
prises faux
je ne sais pas moral par rapport à pour
les blancs donc on a un bel équilibre
on a beaucoup de saveur et on a une
belle richesse à lui que malgré tout
avec des piscines de soleil que la
justice jusqu'au bout le soleil aura
joué avec les nerfs des viticulteurs
mais les vendanges ont bel et bien
commencé